les restaurateurs n'en peuvent plus
après des mois de fermeture entre le
premier et le second confinement c'est
l'overdose
alors que cette situation ne devait
durer que quelques semaines le bout du
tunnel semble encore loin et les
propriétaires de restaurants sont à bout
soto cano nous tuer de m il faut dire
qu'avec toutes ces fermetures imposé et
l'impossibilité d'accueillir des clients
les restaurateurs sont démunis et de
nombreux établissements ont d'ores et
déjà mis la clé sous la porte pour de
bon si des aides ont été prévus par
l'état pour les commerçants certains les
jugent insuffisantes pour d'autres les
vrais coupables sont des assurances
celles ci sont contractées par les
restaurateurs qui sont précisément là
pour les aider en cas de coup dur
sauf que face à la pandémie et l'état
global des commerces certaines
assurances sont aux abonnés absents
une attitude que dénoncent entre autres
le chef jean-françois piège lors du
premier confinement on à déclarer un
sinistre à notre assurance qui nous a
dit vous n'êtes pas couvert par ce que
dans une pandémie il ya une deuxième
fermeture administrative sur le même
territoire quand je les appelle pour
être là non non on n'est pas là on n'est
pas là on n'est pas là alors les
assurances ont-elles coupable de
non-assistance à commerce en danger
merci jean françois pescheux d'être là
et alors et je vous dis aussi le grand
livre de la cuisine française recettes à
des populaire extraordinaire libre de
jean françois piège nous le dit ça c'est
un ouvrage magnifique vous avez lu
chirag line et jean-françois merci
d'être là vous en voulez aux assurances
en particulier à une heure pareille que
vous en voulez à partie quand
particulier à axa pour expliquer à nos
téléspectateurs
parce que c'est vrai que les assurances
dans cette crise sanitaire elles ont un
rôle extrêmement important et vous
considérer qu'elles jouent pas leur rôle
à fond
oui parce que c'est les premiers
aujourd'hui l'état essaye d'arriver avec
des aides mais les aides elles sont
jamais au niveau ils peuvent pas se
substituer en totalité donc on a besoin
d elle des assureurs les assureurs ils
sont pas là et alors on dit souvent les
assurances
ils sont là quand il se passe rien donc
on est là pour mais quand il se passe un
gros truc ils ont dû partager ils sont
pas là du tout parce qu'ils nous disent
que j'ai une une assurance perte
d'exploitation avec une clause épidémie
d'accord il ya une clause qui rajoute si
à une deuxième fermeture vous n'êtes pas
assuré
bien sûr ouais d'accord c'est pas très
clair et comme ce n'est pas très clair
il nous envoie un avenant précisant que
cette fois ci à une pandémie on n'est
pas du tout assurée mais si je vous
envoie un courrier précisant que la
première fois sur 20 c'est ça veut dire
qu'on était ma mère est donc réellement
aujourd'hui sont pas au niveau parce que
on les a assignés en justice
et ils ne veulent rien entendre rien
entendre vous sortez le gouvernement
plutôt de votre côté ou plutôt du côté
des assureurs bien le gouvernement prend
pas parti aujourd'hui à ce niveau là
d'accord si bruno le maire oui oui
monsieur le maire c'est le bruit était
pendant mes vers l'avant la nar bruno le
maire c'est vraiment un piquet c'est le
ministre des sciences et recliquer bruno
le maire s'est impliqué sur le fait
durieux en plus de cantons signe pas en
l'avenant on exclut ce qui est mon cas
et on a une augmentation de la police
d'assurance sans la couverture sur la
perte d'exploitation
donc c'est ce contre ça qui s'est
insurgé moi je m'insurge contre le fait
qu' on a signé un contrat d'assurance
clair sur lequel on est une perte
d'exploitation et que les assureurs ne
couvrent pas cette perte d'exploitation
c'est simple est-ce que vous avez
réfléchi plus payer vos cotisations ce
que vous leur avez je peux pas mettre en
défaut six mois ci
les attaques il faut que je continue à
payer et là ça devient difficile parce
que comme vous le savez tous ces bals et
responchous fermé bien sûr alors oui moi
je verrai les relations l'assureur fait
noter précisément pour être clair avec
le monde
l'assureur est tenu d'un devoir de
conseil au bénéfice de son client
l'assuré et doit les proposer la
couverture du risque donc ils sont en
faute
ils sont venus et les attaquer c'est ce
que c'est ce qu'ont fait ils sont en
faute mais c'est pour ça que je
comprends pas qu'on aille aussi loin
qu'on ait besoin d'aller en justice
parce que c'est extrêmement clair les
assureurs comptent comme les banques en
france est régie par un code d'accord
c'est quelque chose qui est étatique et
je pense que l'état devrait prendre une
décision assez clair contre les
assurances ceux qui ont une couverture
perte d'exploitation devrait être
assurée et puis ce serait normal parce
que ça éviterait à ce que l'état paye
trop de choses sur ce qu'ils sont
assurés s'est pas à l'état à payer c'est
aux assurances alors qu'en plus il
fallait que la fermeture administrative
soit décidée soit par un ministre soit
par un juge ni par une autorité
le préfet nicolas pernikoff n'êtes pas
d'accord avec et je suis pas d'accord et
j'ai pas défendre les assureurs en loin
de là mais la couverture que vous avez
épidémie ou pandémie
elle est rarissime est ce que rend
réalité vous avez des arrêts d'activités
qui sont liés à des sites garanties qui
sont en général le vandalisme
le dégât des eaux et machins et j'ai
compris par contre en interrogeant les
différents assureurs
pourquoi emmanuel macron avait utilisé à
l'époque le mot guerre nous sommes en
guerre pourquoi et pourquoi parce que la
guerre elle n'est jamais assurée n'est
jamais couvert non d'accord il avoue je
vous réponds tout son poids dans le
dernier dans le dernière locution du
présent dans le public il a dit des dix
fois épidémie non non c'est pas non non
non au début craint je vous parle au
début j'en ai abordé au début est un peu
à la première chose qu'il a dit c'est
premier tiers ça a été en guerre c'est
le comment sur la rhétorique jetant sur
cinq pense pas que c'est pas dire qu'il
défend les assurés lorsque je lis juste
dire par là c'est qu'il ya eu quelques
procès effectivement lors de du premier
qu'ovide tout a été gagné aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ils sont en train de prendre
leurs dispositions parce que c'est vrai
que s'ils devaient payer toutes les
pertes d'exploitation décoller en
catastrophe un peu trop clairement on va
pas plaindre les assurances un nom mais
je les plains pas je suis propriétaire
je suis caution personnelle de mes
restaurants mais bien arrive quelque
chose et moi qui vais payer une les
assureurs c'est des salariés et axa ça
fait je sais pas
suis pas un spécialiste ça doit faire
100 milliards d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires ça fait trois ou quatre
milliards de résultat il ya dix-huit
mille contrats qui sont identique au
mien c'est des sources d'axa alors ils
disent entre 15 et 18 on va prendre 18
les restaurants qui sont incriminés
c'est entre 300 et 3 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires la perte
d'exploitation
c'est la marge brute si on confère qu'un
contrat ces trois cent mille euros de
perte d'exploitation on multiplie par
dix huit mille ça fait entre 3 et 4
milliards sachant que le métier
d'assureur sait on assure et on serait
assuré que l on sait rien tout ça là
c'est du blabla d'accord mais c'est du
blabla ah oui vraiment maintenant
d'autant plus moi je suis entièrement
d'accord avec les propos de
jean-françois parce que l'état a joué le
jeu
l'état a joué le jeu l'urssaf a joué le
jouer tout le monde a joué le jeu quand
il a dit on va on va prendre en charge
bastille quand tu montes un dossier oui
non mais je vous le jeu mais si j'ai
appris des restaurateurs ce que moi je
livre des restaurants en fait je
travaille pour un brasseur julie boulet
restant donc j'ai appelé des
restaurateurs ce après midi donc ce qui
s'est passé tu ouvres tu demandes sur
ton compte perso aux impôts sur sa
plateforme de des impôts c'est quand ça
fonctionne mais tu donnes le rib de ta
société et à ce moment-là 6 7 jours
après talent est à l'état qui est venu
ça c'est le premier point
l'étal est venu moi je suis comme vous
ce n'état peut pas tout faire un moment
décès aux assureurs aussi de prendre
leurs responsabilités ce qui se passe
avec les assurances et qui laisse le
vide juridique
ils disent vous n'êtes pas couvert par
pandémie vous n'êtes pas couvert par
crises sanitaires en revanche vous allez
continuer à nous payer nos cotisations
alors trouver un curseur peut-être pas
sur la perte d'exploitation
mais trouver un curseur sur les frêles
et fred les frais du mois par exemple
les fournisseurs qu'il faudra payer à un
moment donné faudra les payer ses
fournisseurs et en continuant à lyon
continue et c'est là que les assurances
doivent venir
c'est là que les instances doivent venir
les fournisseurs les loyers l'état a
pris en charge vos salariés à 84%
même si à une histoire de reçus mais bon
on est on est là dedans mais c'est pris
en charge l'état est pris en charge mais
assure ne jouent pas le jeu ils sont là
pour nous taxer l'argent mais ils
veulent pas rendre quand faut rendre
j'en crois que nous allons mobiliser
d'autres chefs d'autres restaurateurs
autour de votre cause alors sur l'ess
sur la justice on peut pas parce que la
class action n'existe pas en france donc
c'est alors que par dossiers individuels
que les gens concernés aujourd'hui se
mobilisent je pense que
il ya pas mal de dossiers qui sont
déposées et qui vont être déposées parce
que c'est pour ça qu'il faut le dire
c'est ce qu'ils ont une perte
d'exploitation oui dans leur contrat
mobilise et vous allez voir des conseils
et surtout ne laissez vous pas entendre
que vous n'êtes pas assuré parce que moi
la première chose qu'on m'a dit mais
vous êtes passion mais oui et je suis
même pas d'accord parce que là vous
dites c'est vrai vous dites dans vos
contrats vous avez la chance d'avoir un
contrat béton mais nombre de
restaurateurs assuré loi un contrat
béton
ils ont raison les laisse crever et ils
vont quand on va réouvrir les résidents
ont émis les pandémies à des choses
qu'on sait bien sûr et on va rouvrir un
restaurant le mec il a 80 mm
on va lui dire ce que tu roja 80-90
d'être payés quand même la fermeture des
restaurants pour vous c'est une
catastrophe pour vous c'est une
catastrophe pour tout le monde tout fait
dans tous les commerces fermés c'est une
catastrophe suis pas le seul bon j'ai la
chance d'être là ce soir mais il ya des
gens qui peuvent pas parler qishan ainsi
en situation extrêmement compliquée vous
êtes d'accord avec la décision du
gouvernement ou de je peux pas rentrer
dans cette polémique là moi je suspens
je suis pas spécialiste
ce que je sais faire c'est sait faire le
métier de restaurateur savoir si fort et
ouvrait aux pas réouvrir
il ya des gens qui sont concernés je
n'entrais pas dans cette polémique mais
si on nous ferme si on nationalise nos
fermeture il faut qu'on nationalise nos
pertes
on peut pas nous laisser assumer à nous
les pertes pas parce que ce soit à
travers l'état qui doit aller jusqu'au
bout des z
parce que ils ont fait une partie du
chemin mais doivent aller jusqu'au bout
je dis pas de gains jeudi de pertes
il faut pas faut pas qu on sait qu'on va
gagner de l'argent maintenant cet argent
il est là ça passe il rentre juste pour
ressortir mais pour l'instant ils
rentrent pas suffisamment il ressort
beaucoup c'est ça l'image de dire aux
assureurs maintenant prenez vous aussi
les responsables c'est d'être une côte
en ouverture ans on sait très bien
qu'ils feront rien ils font du chantage
à l'assurance et à l'état de mettre les
gens sur ce voyage